[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute nichts
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den
sportverein sogenannter von heute ging
es los auf schloss elmau
der g 7 gipfel in bayern präsident biden
und bundeskanzler scholz beschwören die
geschlossenheit gegenüber russland
erneut angriffe auf kiew russische
raketen schlagen in der ukrainischen
hauptstadt ein eine siebenjährige wird
aus den trümmern gerettet
und freude über gold die deutschen
freiwasser staffel um florian wellbrock
schwimmt zum weltmeistertitel
ein gipfel im zeiten des krieges uns
eint der glaube an demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit
sagt der bundeskanzler zum auftakt und
auch der us-präsident betont wir werden
wir müssen zusammenbleiben
mit als erstes auf dem programm das
traditionelle gruppenfoto eingerahmt von
den eu spitzen die staatenlenker aus
italien kanada frankreich deutschland
den usa großbritannien und japan
daniel pontzen über die ersten stunden
dieses krisengipfels
so fragte kanzler ob er der us-präsident
sich bitte eben ein drehen könne fürs
foto bilder sind wichtige währung bei
solchen gipfeln erst recht jetzt der
zusammenhalt demonstrieren so wichtig
ist wichtig daher auch freundschaftliche
zwischentöne damit war joe biden schon
zuvor vor einem vier augen gespräch sehr
großzügig umgegangen und kranken ich
möchte sie dazu beglückwünschen dass sie
so vorangegangen sind sie kanzler wurden
und damit einen großen einfluss auf das
übrige europa hatten vor allem mit blick
auf die ukraine
der krieg dort die größte von derzeit so
vielen so vielschichtigen krisen deshalb
bin ich sehr froh dass wir hier so viel
zeit haben miteinander zu sprechen ganz
entfernt von den typischen
formalisierten abläufen und auch so dass
jeder das sagt was ihm wirklich auf dem
herzen liegt das hat schon gleich bei
der ersten sitzung so geklappt thema
darin weltwirtschaftlicher
herausforderungen energieknappheit
lieferketten inflation zudem im fokus
die eskalierende ernährungskrise
russland soll dafür allein
verantwortlich spiele ein gefährliches
hunger spiel so der eu ratspräsident
durch das blockieren von häfen angriffe
auf kritische infrastrukturen dadurch
dass weizenfeldern schlachtfelder
verwandelt werden müssen familien und
kinder hunger leiden
da vinci thema der dritten
arbeitssitzung am abend außen und
sicherheitspolitik hierbei und bei den
anderen themen geht es auch um die
einbindung der gastländer große
demokratien wie südafrika indien
indonesien die morgen dazu stoßen wir
wollen der welt zeigen dass demokratien
wenn sie zusammenarbeiten den besten weg
zu ergebnissen ebenen für unsere
bevölkerung und alle menschen weltweit
ob beim klima bei gesundheit sicherheit
und digitaler innovationen digital
innovation das wetter die atmosphäre die
kulisse all das stimmt offen ist wie
substanziell man am ende tatsächlich
vorankommt
drei tage dauert dieser gipfel anne
gellinek was ist das wichtigste ziel
das signal das von hier aus nach moskau
gehen soll ist das bild des
schulterschlusses der geschlossenheit
und der ausdauer was die weitere
unterstützung der ukraine an betrifft
alle hier wissen dass je länger dieser
krieg dauert desto schwieriger je
schwieriger wird die die der westliche
zusammenhalt die sieben staats und
regierungschefs haben sich heute mit den
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen des
ukraine kriegs befasst auch mit den
steigenden energiepreisen und dabei
wurden erste risse deutlich der
amerikanische präsident joe biden
wünscht sich eine deckelung des
russischen ölpreises die europäer sind
eher skeptisch ob sich das weltweit
durchsetzen lässt frage auch welche
schweren waffen wird man weiterhin an
die ukraine liefern ohne sich selbst zur
kriegspartei zu machen all das werden
die sieben chefs jetzt beim abendessen
vertraulich nur mit ihren engsten
beratern hier auf schloss elmau
besprechen live vom gipfel war dass anne
gellinek vielen dank
auch heute gab es proteste gegen den
gipfel rund 800 demonstrierende
versammelten sich laut polizei bei der
größten veranstaltung in garmisch
partenkirchen
der demonstrationszug verlief weitgehend
friedlich begleitet wurde er von einem
massiven aufgebot an sicherheitskräften
insgesamt fielen die proteste bislang
deutlich kleiner aus als erwartet
alle entwicklungen rund um den g 7
gipfel finden sie in unserer zdf heute
app dort halten wir sie unter anderem
mit einem live blog auf dem laufenden
morgen wird der ukrainische präsident
lenski zum gipfel zugeschaltet er
fordert dringend mehrere waffen sein
land stecke in einer moralisch und
emotional schwierigen phase des krieges
im osten gewinnen die russen immer mehr
an boden heute griffen sie erstmals auch
wieder kiew an pablo c lala hier hat mir
ein siebenjähriges mädchen im schlaf von
einer russischen rakete überrascht am
morgen können kind und mutter lebend aus
den trümmern eines wohnhauses gerettet
werden mindestens 14 raketen sollen in
der nacht in kiew und umgebung
eingeschlagen seien eine davon auf dem
gelände eines kindergartens es ist der
erste russische angriff auf die
hauptstadt seit gut drei wochen oder
meister klitschko glaubt angesichts des
g7 treffens und des nato gipfels der am
dienstag beginnt nicht an einen zufall
vielleicht ist das symbolisch ein
solcher angriff in diesen tagen
nach vier monaten krieg sie präsident
sie lenski die ukraine in einer
schwierigen phase
wir haben kein gefühl dafür wie lange es
dauern wird wie viele schläge verluste
und anstrengungen noch nötig sein werden
bevor wir sehen dass der sieg in sicht
ist
die lenski kündigt an alle von russland
kontrollierten städte zurückzuerobern
nach der einnahme der strategisch
wichtigen stadt server donetsk in der
ost ukraine gestern sollen russische
truppen nun auch über den fluss in die
nachbarstadt lizenz vorgedrungen sein
russland veröffentlichte indes heute
diese bilder verteidigungsminister shaul
gut trifft soldaten die in der ukraine
im einsatz sind wo genau die aufnahmen
entstanden unklar nachdem sich die
russische offensive in den letzten
wochen auf die ost ukraine konzentrierte
nimmt moskau nun auch wieder städte im
westen des landes ins visier
auf ihrem parteitag in erfurt hat sich
auch die linkspartei zum ukraine krieg
positioniert sie kritisierte russlands
vorgehen scharf waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine lehnt die partei aber weiterhin
ab die delegierten hatten gestern janine
wissler und martin schirdewahn zum neuen
führungsduo gewählt
eine schwierige tarifrunde steht an die
gewerkschaften fordern einen ausgleich
für die inflation das aber könnte die
teuerung weiter anheizen der
bundeskanzler will nach presseberichten
einen möglichen ausweg vorschlagen die
arbeitgeber leisten einmalzahlungen die
bleiben steuerfrei und die
gewerkschaften sollen im gegenzug ihre
lohnforderungen dämpfen anfang juli will
scholz mit arbeitgebern und
gewerkschaften über die inflation und
deren folgen sprechen und noch eine idee
der bundesregierung wegen engpässen an
deutschen flughäfen will sie befristet
ausländische hilfskräfte zu lassen ziel
sei es dass bereits ab juli mehrere
tausend arbeitskräfte einspringen die
urlaubssaison hat er an vielen flughäfen
chaotisch begonnen einer studie zufolge
fehlen derzeit rund
7200 mitarbeiter zb in der
gepäckabfertigung und damit sind wir
beim sport großer jubel bei der
deutschen freiwasser staffel norbert die
sind wieder weltmeister ja eine
erfolgreiche und vor allem hart
erkämpfte titelverteidigung das quartett
aus oliver klee mit leonie beck und
florian wellbrock gewinnt gold über 4 x
1,5 kilometer unter teilweise
chaotischen umständen
startschwimmerin lea bei hat als einzige
den titel schon bei der letzten wm mit
gewonnen eine hilfreiche erfahrung der
die männliche konkurrenz auf ihrer
ersten runde nimmt vor ihr eine
abkürzung und wird disqualifiziert boy
behält die übersicht und ihr team vorne
nach oliver klemmenden leonie beck
bringt das starke finish von florian
wellbrock den sieg vor ungarn und
italien für wellbrock ist es nach bronze
und silber die dritte medaille in
budapest der mixed staffel wm titel geht
wie 2009/10 an deutschland
ein ex ultra ist neuer härter präsident
kai bernstein der 41 jährige unternehmer
war früher vorsänger in der berliner
fankurve jetzt ist der nachfolger von
werner gegenbauer der nach 14 jahren
zurück getreten war letzter tag der
finale 190 deutsche meister titel sind
vergeben einer der höhepunkte vor einer
knappen halben stunde die entscheidung
im weitsprung der frauen die
olympiasiegerin von tokio malaika me
hamburg verteidigt ihren titel souverän
die 28 jährige heidelbergerin wird ihre
ausnahmestellung gerecht und springt im
dritten versuch gute 685 auf der theater
und sprintdistanz 750 meter schwimmen 20
kilometer radfahren und fünf kilometer
laufen er kämpft lassen es buschhütten
den meistertitel vor lasse nygaard
priester quickborn titel am paradegerät
für pauline schäfer betz aus chemnitz
trotz kleinerer patzer distanziert die
weltmeisterin von 2017 ihre konkurrentin
schrecksekunde für oliver widmann im try
bericht die gabel des 26 zoll rats doch
der 20 jährige weltklasse mann aus
ludwigsburg verteidigt trotzdem seinen
meistertitel nach drei fehlstarts
gewinnt der kölner joshua hartmann in
einer top zeit von 20 32 von ansa aus
hamburg die 200 meter und
das war's von den finanz- und heute vom
sport dankeschön das wetter wird mancher
orts turbulent im osten und südosten
noch länger sonnig sonst wechselnd oder
stark bewölkt und zeitweise regen oder
gewitter dabei unwettergefahr durch
starkregen hagel und schwere sturmböen
19 bis 26 grad im westen im osten bis zu
35 grad heiß wir sagen tschüss und
wünschen ihnen einen guten start in die
neue woche um viertel vor zehn begrüßt
sie christian sievers mit dem heute
journal vom g7 gipfel und hier übernimmt
jetzt live vom gipfel geschehen theo
koll